bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en duplex de strasbourg pour retrouver
le premier vice président de la
commission européenne france timmermans
la commission va présenter a présenté ce
mardi un plan visant à réduire les
importations de gaz en provenance de
russie suite à à son invasion de
l'ukraine des mesures qui me prévoit
notamment la mise en place de stockage
stratégique et de diversification des
approvisionnements pour réduire de deux
tiers d'un dépendance au gaz russe comme
comment on va y parvenir vraiment frans
timmermans
bon on doit réduire aussi la
consommation de notre énergie on doit
appliquer au plus vite possible
la transition vers l'énergie
renouvelable et on doit trouver d'autres
fournisseurs d'énergie en dehors de la
russie donc en une combinaison entre ces
mesures nous peut mettre dans une
situation de réduire nos importations de
gaz naturel par deux tiers avant la fin
de l'année alors dans cette feuille de
route en effet il n'est plus tout à fait
tabou de pas de reparler d'un recours
temporaire au charbon ça met quand même
en cause un petit peu votre idée de
pacte vert si on peut retourner vers des
énergies très polluantes comme le
charbon notamment pour se débarrasser de
notre dépendance à la russie
ce qu'on doit atteindre ces c'est une
obligation légale
c'est d'arriver à une réduction des
émissions d'au moins 55% d'ici 2030 et
de réussir une neutralité climatique
d'ici 2050 ça n'a pas changé donc si on
veut utiliser le charbon un peu plus
long il faudra introduire les énergies
renouvelables plutôt plus tôt que prévu
avant donc dans cette combinaison c'est
toujours possible si on veut réduire sa
dépendance sur le gaz naturel russe on
peut imaginer une autre stratégie mais
chaque stratégie demande une
introduction des renouvelables plus vite
que prévu auparavant à titre de sanction
l'ukraine le président ukrainien demande
de bloquer les importations de pétrole
russes les américains sont plutôt pour
les européens très divisés sur le sujet
oui rien n'est rien et interdit tout est
toujours sur la table je suis sûr que
nos chefs d'état de gouvernement en
reparlerons à versailles jeudi et
vendredi mais quand on impose des
sanctions il faut quand même savoir que
celui auquel on pose ses sanctions et
plus touchés par ces sanctions que celui
qui les imposent donc quand on fait ce
choix il faut être sûr qu'on frappe
surtout poutine est pas nous mêmes donc
c'est dans cette danse est pensé qu'on
essaie de développer des sanctions qui
touchent le régime de poutine et
tout est encore possible et je suis
convaincu que nos chefs d'état du
gouvernement en reparlerons à versailles
je dis merci à vous monsieur le vice
président de la commission européenne de
nous avoir parlé de ce grand plan pour
diversifier notre approvisionnement
énergétique
[Musique]